das sind sie die wunderbaren verlierer
die wasserträger des radsports
sie fahren im dienste ihres teamchefs
versorgen ihn bieten windschatten ackern
wie die berserker
damit ihr wieder gewinnt wonderful user
das ist eine fast schon liebevolle
hommage an die wasserträger beim giro
d'italia
ein film der den radrennsport diesen
brutalen sport aus der perspektive
derjenigen erzählt die nie gewinne
werden die permanent ihre physischen und
mentalen widerstände brechen
das fasziniert ab der ersten minute
dieser blick in eine irritierend fremde
welt auf diese starken charaktere
apropos rosa krawatte com für sie ist es
eine arbeit wie jede andere
es ist ihr job sich nicht auf sich
selbst zu konzentrieren sondern auf den
sieg des leaders ihm zu helfen wo immer
sie können
sie müssen sich selbst vergessen können
marc alexa war produzent und kameramann
von wonderful users der westschweizer
filmte eben jene die sich selbst
vergessen
die kamera ist nah an ihnen dran
fast intim schon gnadenlos aber nie
voyeuristisch zeigt sie unmenschliche
leistungen drangsalierte körper und
schmerzen immer wieder schmerzen
sid
das ist wirklich eine andere philosophie
leben
man akzeptiert dass man sich sehr wehtun
und erwartet schließlich davon etwas
größeres man sagt ja dass man sich oft
gerade im schmerz am besten kennt sich
findet erkennt wenn man im inneren ist
man wünscht diesen rennfahrern dass sie
tatsächlich irgendeinen mentalen gewinn
daraus ziehen dass sie nach brutalen
stürzen und selbst mit einer
gehirnerschütterung weiter
[Musik]
fest steht sie wollen aber sie müssen
auch weiterfahren
orchestriert vom teammanager im auto
auch das erzählt der film am rande diese
rennfahrer sind ein wenig wie mönche
sechs stunden lang die ptv das ist fast
schon ein mann trat
und so sitzt man atemlos im kino und
fragt sich wie man zu so viel
aufopferung fähig sein kann